in the battle to defend ukraine the west
has opened a new front one in which the
weapons are economic the targets russian
wealth hidden abroad and its financial
system at home all part of an economic
assault on an unprecedented scale the
latest salvo the uk joining the european
union united states and switzerland in
hobbling russia's central bank by
cutting access to sterling and uk money
markets with over 50 per cent of russian
trade
denominated in dollars or sterling our
coordinated action with the united
states will damage russia's ability to
trade with the world
and as soon as this legislation comes
into force we will apply it to spare
bank russia's largest bank
russian flag ships are now banned from
uk ports too including those carrying
oil
while shell announced it is ending a
three billion dollar partnership with
energy giant gazprom days after bp was
forced to sell its russian holdings in a
globalized economy driven by oil and gas
making a financial pariah of russia will
come at a cost it's clear that russia
will suffer the greater pain but we must
not think for a moment that there won't
be a rebound that they won't be blow
back i think there will be because the
global economy is so integrated and in
particular integrated with the russian
economy 300 billion dollars a year some
people think that's peanuts in terms of
the global financial system but it does
it will hurt
a new economic crimes bill will target
individuals preventing property owners
hiding behind shell companies and in
time making it easier to target putin's
allies so often those of us in the uk
like to point the finger elsewhere at
other countries and point out the
corruption there but the fact is the uk
is complicit in global corruption in
laundering the world's dirty money we've
been doing it for decades and i think
it's such a shame it's taken so long for
these measures to be brought forward but
now i would really encourage the
government to make sure they bite as
soon as possible
at the russian embassy protests continue
it's a stone's throw from kensington
palace the heart of a community of the
super-rich that's grown in plain sight
for two decades it's taken war in europe
to prompt government action against
london's oligarchs but for those close
to vladimir putin any pain will be
relative the real aim of this financial
assault is to trigger an economic crisis
at home that turns ordinary russians
against their leader
western governments say more sanctions
are coming their hope that financial
muscle can outflank military might paul
kelso sky news